pelé gaudreault bonsoir tout un contrat
oui effectivement
puis vous le vouliez là c'est pas à pas
forcés que vous le vouliez que j'étais
candidat vous même oui absolument
acheter candidat parce que je crois
fondamentalement à la mission que notre
raison d'être
bon on l'a vu ça c'est partir à lyon
avec gilles vaillancourt que plaider
coupable donc beaucoup de l'arrestation
beaucoup de coqs qui sont tombés pour le
vus encore il ya deux semaines
qu'est ce qui est arrivé vous avez voulu
aller trop vite l'upac les preuves
étaient insuffisantes
c'est quoi le mal qui fait que tous ces
gens le sang soit c'est certain que pour
nous c'est essentiel d'être de
travailler de façon très professionnelle
est justement de respecter les
différents processus qui ne sont
imposées par les tribunaux
aujourd'hui on a des choses avec
lesquelles on doit composer la trame à
la région donne par exemple on doit
présenter une preuve plus complète ou
poursuivants pour que ces derniers
puissent déposer des accusations
on est dans cette transition là en ce
moment tout aimé la preuve dans
plusieurs cas auraient été mal rassemblé
tournée incursion à quitter
pierre duhaime on a retenu un des seuls
chefs pablo catania harry jordan vous
l'avez dit ça trop traîné frank zampino
a quitté jeudi c'est pas un cas parmi
donc là c'est une série de revers grave
non je conviens avec vous
qu'effectivement la perception du public
notamment peut être vraiment de dire ben
coudon s qui travaillent
professionnellement je vous ai bonne
chose par contre moi je suis convaincu
qu'un échec devant un tribunal et pro
nécessairement un échec pour l'anc est
en tant que tel la preuve de faire
affaire pour la corruption est
extrêmement complexe et on se doit
absolument de souvent de se relier sur
des informations qui sont quand même
assez espacées dans le temps des
témoignages la preuve donc plus d'estimé
niall et le test des tribunaux est
excessivement exigeant donc on travaille
dans ce sens oui bien sûr mais on savait
tout chat avant de porter des
accusations avant qu avant que l'upac
l'exil ya des tests
heureusement que le test des tribunaux
est exigeant mais pas dans le code de
frank zampino par exemple est ce pas une
erreur de pee wee d'avoir écouté les
conversations alors qu'il parle à son
avocat ben écoutez ça il ya encore de
roma aurait pas seulement due
du procès d'un récit d'un pinot en
particulier parce qu'il est encore
devant les tribunaux si elle rappelé
cependant je dois vous assurez une autre
suggestion la population des gens qui
nous écoutent
on travaille exclusivement en lien avec
les obligations qu'ils trouvent une fois
on fera pas de choses cavaliere on
travaille pas qu'au bois et je vous
assure là dessus de professionnalisme
votre prédécesseur pour va coûter un
tout petit extrait c'est très court
avait dit oui ça peut être long mais
vous allez voir ça va marcher les
grosses enquêtes
il fait référence la halle enquête
machuret sur l'argent illégales perçues
par le parti libéral peut-être on écoute
on vient ça va toujours des deux lots il
y en a un en trop qui un jour va bouter
on est rendu à 9,1 monsieur le député
mais on va arriver à la conclusion
puis j'ai bien l'impression qu'on va
mettre des bracelets ces jeunes mais ça
fait neuf ans est ce que monsieur
lafreniere avait vendu la peau de l'ours
avant de l'avoir tué inscrits de dieu
qui va voir des bracelets dans ma chaire
et puis ne se fait pas de 9 ans a fait
aux applis arrive rien qu'est-ce qui se
passe vous savez une décision que j'ai
prise moi personnellement c'est d'éviter
à tout prix de parler nos doux aussi
dans la quête en cours ça peut en fait
ça peut créer des attentes
cette énumération écoutez moi je
l'aurais pas fait que je leur ai pas
fait pour la raison très simple qu'on
doit respecter justement le processus
judiciaire dans son ensemble et avant de
se prononcer sur la place publique en
évoquant des résultats
je pense que c'est très hasardeuse et
moi j'ai pris à des sons qu'on ne le
ferai plus dans l'avenir
qui alors ctoc est là j'allais vous
demandez est ce qu'elle est encore
active ce que ça va donner des résultats
machuret pour prendre l'exemple
sans parler d'un cas en particulier ce
que je peux vous dire moi c'est que dès
mon arrivée en poste je demande à mes
gestionnaire d'exercer une révision
complète de l'ensemble de nos doux aussi
a répondu que m'a juré en particulier ou
d'un autre corps cependant ma première
préoccupation c'est de m'assurer que les
enquêtes sont bien conduire
professionnellement dans le but éventuel
de pouvoir convaincre le dpcp de nous
accompagner dans son ciel est ce que
vous vous êtes convaincu aujourd'hui qui
a jamais eu
ni de pressions politiques ni de
motivation politique dans les enquêtes
je vous donne un exemple l'arrestation
de nathalie normandeau le jour d'un
budget du québec
ça peut pas être un hasard ces choses là
quand même moi j'étais pas lieu à ce
moment là je peux pas expliquer les
décisions qui ont amené à ces
circonstances là cependant moi je peux
vous assurer d'une chose depuis je suis
en poste je n'ai jamais eu aucune
pression politique et par ailleurs c'est
pas pour sûr que je fais le travail
je le fais parce que je suis convaincu
de la mission les gens qui font le
travail au quotidien chez nous sont
également convaincus
alors pour nous il n'y a pas d'agenda
politique dans une enquête bon là avant
de vous laisser aller vous allez
m'expliquer une chose on a vous avez
votre prédécesseur a lancé une enquête
sur les fuites
on sait qu'il y avait des fruits et eu
de tout temps des frites importante à
l'upac d'ailleurs ce que permis de
nombreux reportages ici ailleurs
l'anc est le projet à s'était imposé
pour connaître l'origine de ces frites
là on arrête du où elle est ça donne
rien le jamais accuser c'est bien
compliqué de comprendre qui a fuité des
choses chez vous comprenez vous que
c'est ce que ça fait que ça fait que de
poissons cette histoire en fait ça fait
que de poisson par une place alimente le
cynisme
oui j'en avais haute institution je
regrette profondément
parce que je peux vous dire d'ailleurs
c'est une décision que j'ai prise quand
je suis revenu ont fait pas continuer
assure tout entier et et c'est pourquoi
j'ai fait la demande
que ça soit une autre entité qui fasse
ce qui conduit cette enquête
je pense que aujourd'hui on est en
mesure de dire que nos enquêtes qui sont
en cours présentement sont faites de
façon extrêmement professionnelle et que
si une situation similaire soit
représenterait on prendrait pas la même
décision qui a été prise à l'époque mais
vous dites que tous ces mois là ces
années là même on n'a pas su identifier
qui coulait des choses à l'upac je peux
pas vraiment parler de ce dossier là
évidemment comprendre il ya une enquête
en cours présentement qui conduite par
un autre entité berry et c'est une
descente j'ai pris très rapidement
arrivée en poste parce que pour moi
c'était incongru de faire ça alors
cependant je pense sincèrement commenté
sur cette enquête en tant qu elle
j'espère qu'un jour par contre on adhère
est ce qu on a encore besoin de l'upac
autant qu'avant moi je suis convaincu
une soif savez au canada on est la seule
province une unité permanente
anticorruption
les sept dernières années on a quand
même un bilan reluisant près de 200
arrestations 90 condamnation je mets au
défi de trouver une autre province au
canada qui autant de résultats en même
temps on est présent sur le terrain on
fait de la prévention en matière de
lutte contre la corruption a rencontré
25000 titulaires de charges publiques
dans les dernières années ont fait de la
bf qu'elles sont en collaboration avec
l'autorité des marchés publics non
content de notre raison d'être
avez vous assez d'experts avez vous
assez de gens qui connaissent
l'informatique parce qu'on al'impression
vous butez à l'absence de preuves
évidentes dans plusieurs dossiers qui
tombe en a parlé est ce que vous avez
est ce que votre expertise est
suffisante chez vous elle ne sera jamais
assez suffisante
il a raison est simple ça évolue très
rapidement on prend les chercheurs et à
chercher les experts de contenu vraiment
dans un marché où il quand même une
forte compétition faut innover en ce
moment de l'opportunité d'avoir créé
notre corps de police dans les deux
trois prochaines années on est en
construction on va pouvoir définir
qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin comme comme
professionnels en matière de temps de
corruption vous êtes là pour sept ans
est ce que vous faites aussi le pari
vous dites je ne parlerai pas comme mon
prédécesseur des enquêtes
je vais pas vous annoncer des bracelets
des arrestations mais faites vous quand
même le pari d'une certaine transparence
ouais en fait ce pari c'est un
engagement que je prends devant vous ce
soir l'important pour moi c'est de
montrer que notre organisation elle est
très transparent par ailleurs on a un
comité de surveillance permanent qui en
fait sont les seuls car de police au
québec et le comité de surveillance
permanente sauvé nos activités donc on
doit être transparent on doit faire une
reddition de comptes sur la façon qu'on
administre nos dossiers nos enquêtes
mais évidemment je ne parlerai pas des
enquêtes active parce qu'il ya toujours
un risque évidemment que finalement on
frappe un mur son père de nos enquêtes
active mais je tiens à vous rassurer
vous et l'ensemble des gens qu'on est là
pour les bonnes raisons détails sur
l'anc est ma chérie quand mais je vous
demande pas de me parler de l'enquète
sauf que pour les gens visés là ce que
ça va durer avis lankais est ce qu'à un
moment donné vous allez dire compte tenu
des preuves amassées de la preuve
amassée insuffisante ou sucre si elles
suffisantes il ya des accusations ci est
insuffisante avaient voulu aller
dire un jour clairement je pense qu'il
ya des décisions parfois qu'il faut
prendre des orientations il faut prendre
et je vais les assumer je vais les
prendre en temps et lieu sans parler du
doubs aussi en tant que tel il y aurait
alors un jour il y aura effectivement
parce que malheureusement il ya des gens
qui je parle pas dans le camp
particulier des gens qui ont été ciblés
médiatiquement comme étaient en fait des
suspects potentiels dans certains
dossiers
on devra un jour monsieur bigourdans
scoci par exemple j'imagine dix accusés
nous nous dit vous n'avez pas cette
preuve me dit quelque chose
absolument je pense que là dessus on
peut mais avec une enquête est toujours
vivante
il ya toujours des nouveaux éléments des
nouveaux cinémas et d'ailleurs
j'encourage les gens dans mon bain en
fait ma relation de confiance que je
rétablis à ne pas hésiter à nos séries
lorsqu'ils sont témoins d'actes qui
peuvent s'apparenter à de la corruption
répondre on se reparlera alors bonne
chance vers c'est tout un défi l'upac
merci beaucoup à la prochaine merci
monsieur roy voix